un bourg paisible et tranquille qui
pourrait rester ainsi pendant tout le
week end
même si cette boulangerie attend
l'événement on se frotteront les mains
ça nous ramène de la clientèle on est
content tient pas redemander attend on
attend d'eux mais avec impatience et
dimanche
et voilà le jour d'après me lundi on a
ce qui reste là les résidents donc il
profite le lundi devenait haché le petit
jean
en revanche cette épicerie et cet
organisateur de soirées s'interroge sur
les réelles retombées d'un pareil
événement pour les commerçants de
proximité un dispositif identique à
celui du tour des yoles a été retenue le
gourou sera fermé cinq parkings
extérieurs et des navettes sont prévues
jusqu'à la pole à moi messieurs marc
licence iv fut pas censés devoir vendre
de l'alcool
or c'est mon activité principale donc je
sais pas si c'est forcément judicieux je
dirais pas que c'est une mauvaise chose
je sais pas si on avoir moins d eau de
retombées directes
économiquement parlant au départ il faut
qu'ils aient des la concertation il faut
qu'il y ait un calendrier qui nous
permettent de mettre en place des
promotions en sorte que les gens
viennent chez nous et que sa voix qu'il
ya quand même des commerces de proximité
qui peuvent répondre alors à leurs
attentes en termes de manifestations
les restaurateurs de la pointe fola
s'interroge également sur leurs
activités du week end ce qui fonde la
restauration rapide
il trouve forcément leur compte les
autres préfèrent rester fermés même
s'ils comprennent l'existence d'un tel
festival
c'est une clientèle jeune c est vraiment
du gène des jeunes j'en mettrais bien
une bonne organisation parfaite et
c'est pas nos clients qui viennent
manger
comme le maudit et voilà quoi moi étant
donné que quand même j'habite le
restaurant derrière le restaurant je
vais ouvrir ce que je veux montrer aussi
qu'il faut se battre et que moi je suis
là pour me battre pour avoir des clients
alors qu'on dise les organisateurs et
aux atouts que j'ai eus par rapport à
l'année dernière étaient les suivants
sous les festivals et qui sont qui ont
quitté le festival ont mangé c'est tous
les restaurateurs qui étaient présents
jusqu'à ce jusqu'au snack qui était au
niveau du vauclin mais c'est vrai que
pas pour restaurateurs du voc les mêmes
fautes qu'on trouve une formule trouvée
comme on fait un projet global sur le
voka n'est pas que cela sonne faux là et
que pour le festival puisse intégrer
facilement dans la commune
le festival commence demain midi les
organisateurs espèrent atteindre le
chiffre des vingt mille participants